hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today's Thursday it's dead stream
recap day we have a few things to talk
about like the road map for March to
April for foreign or anything that's
been going on it's gonna be going on in
the near months as well as some console
dedicated server news so let's get
started so first to get the obvious one
out of the way console dedicated servers
have come out on Tuesday if you haven't
played it all since couple days ago that
being Tuesday then console dedicated
servers are out for ps4 and Xbox
everyone already knows PC already has it
but the consoles didn't get it so like I
said as of Tuesday we are a fish we
officially have dedicated servers which
means we should hopefully not be lagging
out of matches personally from my
experience I've played a decent amount
of matches from Tuesday and on Wednesday
and I have yet to disconnect from a
single match which is super good news so
congrats to the for on our dev team for
making it work and hopefully hopefully
it continues to stay spotless next up we
have before on our roadmap for March and
April I will put the photo on screen for
you so that you guys can understand what
I'm looking at and basically to start
off March 15th is going to be season 5
campaign 3 which it basically is just
the rounds that we go through or the
campaigns that we go through during the
faction war super easy it's just it's
normal campaign
we're also be going to beginning
realistic Dominion I'm assuming for the
in for an entire week starting March
15th which is cool realistic Dominion if
you guys don't know is regular Dominion
but it's in realistic game mode from the
campaign meaning we're not getting any
Guard stance which is I'm assuming no
gear stats and stuff like that so you're
going to have to play based off of
memory of the attack instead of just
looking at your gear your guard stance
there's also something else that's going
to be locked I have no clue what that
happens to be it might be a challenge it
might be some type of content of the
week
I have no absolute clue but it'd be
really nice to figure out what those are
since there seems to be at least five of
them displayed on this roadmap the
weekend event is going to be the
dominant executioner I'm assuming it's
probably going to be somewhere regarding
executions in Dominion or something
regarding that maybe last week where the
factions had to go up against each other
to see who won the event moving to march
23rd we're going to be getting another
double xp fest so if you need to wrap up
another character throughout the weekend
definitely want to utilize that from
March 23rd to 26th on the 29th of March
we're so Stu beginning some type of
event I'm assuming this is somewhere
catered toward the faction executions
think we just got recently because if
you don't know the winner
of that got steal rewards and create
rewards so I'm assuming that's something
similar to that as in terms of the word
vanquish rush I have absolutely no clue
if you guys have any speculations or
ideas tell me in the comments below I'd
love to know your thoughts and then next
thing is on in the April section on
April 5th dance of death is going to be
coming back if you have no clue I did a
collab but spliced on that but other
than that it's basically a 2v2 brawl
where you have to kill the opponent at
the same exact time within a certain
time frame for you to end the round it's
not like a normal bra match for once the
person dies they die if they die the
second person has to die as well or the
first person will respawn it's actually
a lot of fun it was probably one of my
favorite game modes next to ice brawler
so I'm very glad that that is coming
back one big things the devil the devs
also did stay is that they said just
because the new training trials and the
arena mode is not on the roadmap does
not mean they're coming out anytime soon
they're still planning I'm releasing it
but it could be it could be during this
road map time that could not they don't
want to give it a set date and then have
it not be accomplished on that date next
up is the new content of the week we're
gonna be getting three new battle off
it's nothing too crazy I've never been
into battle if it's that much I'll show
it in the background of course while I
talk but yes you can buy those for your
character if if you do want those
personally for me I'm not gonna be
buying them I'm more of a mythic and
elite type guy battle outfits really
aren't my thing and then there was some
other info talked about in the stream
just a little bits of tad information
that I'd love to share with you guys
four before ranked player progression
will also be changed as well to fit more
and be more fair to players and the
steel and XP rewards are going to be
slightly increased they're still working
on a master rank type thing but there's
no ETA and when that arrives if you guys
don't remember the rankings I believe
our bronze silver gold diamond and plar
platinum then diamond there's nothing
past Diamond but I'm assuming they're
going to add a master rank for the very
good players so that would be definitely
interesting to check out I myself ain't
that good I think the highest I've ever
gotten was gold 3 so I'm really not that
great at this game that's why I cover
the news for it the devs also said that
they're going to be working on more
character reworks the but they haven't
given any info at just this time let me
guys let me know what you guys think in
the comments about this let me know what
heroes you guys think me the most
reworks I think Orochi and Valcke are
the top two choices for reworks in my
opinion let me know what you guys think
in the comments below drew love
No and that is the last of the
information guys there wasn't really
much on this stream but either way that
was a few bits of info wanted to share
with you but that's going to be the end
of the video like the video if you guys
did enjoy real quick I just want to
state that I'm gonna be posting two
other videos after this they aren't
going to be for honor related they are
going to be for tonight related I
decided to get into for tonight I've
been playing at a lot since the season 3
came out about two weeks ago I've been
playing with a couple of my friends I
decided I'd do a few YouTube videos on
it since I do enjoy the game that's kind
of what I wanted to do if you guys do
want to check those out I'll be super
appreciated if you do if you don't
that's completely fine but I really
would be so happy if you guys could
check those out they're gonna be coming
out like an hour or two be the way like
I said like the video if you guys did
enjoy a subscriber if we knew I cover
the four on her news the least the
discussion all that good stuff about for
honor the informational side my two most
recent videos are gonna be popping up on
screen if you guys haven't seen those
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest today and peace out